hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute endlich zum zweiten
teil von breakout ab die zahlreich drauf
gewartet von daher würde ich sagen
verliere gar nicht lange zeit und machen
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten rätsel
fahre mit dem auto bis zum straßenschild
peter stein davor
ich weiß nicht ob wir den stein kleiner
ziehen können ob wir irgendwas rum
ziehen können gegen das drücken
die folge ich kann ich kann den text ich
habe was bringt mir das mit dem text die
wolken tief da ist eine sonne alba zwei
steile wieder da
wie isst man karotten ist das nächste
rätsel ist ein hase und ich kann mit dem
hier rüber dann fällt allerdings runter
und das ist falsch da kommt er wieder
dahin ich gerade dies auch springen
ich kann die karotte einfach zu sehr
bald kommen ein physik buch der debis
frost auf jeden fall hilft ihnen den
fluss zu überqueren also wir haben links
die liebe annette und rechts den lieben
achim und qimonda lette sind ein ganz
liebes liebespärchen und die wollen sich
die ich habe so einen krassen bizeps ich
habe einfach kurz das brot von denen
doppelt so groß gemacht
nächstes rätsel welche drei nummern
addieren sich zu zwölf wir haben 93 da
sind dann allerdings nur zwei nummern
wir haben drei +5 sind acht plus gehabt
drei nummern welche drei nummern
addieren sich zu 12 wenn wir die drei
geringsten zahlenwerte nehmen also 3 5
und 6 selbst das sind schon 14
wie sollen das dann klappen
ich bin der jüngste mensch der welt ich
nehme einfach 3 3 und 6 und das sind 12
das physik buch wird noch gekämpft wird
lege alles in die schachtel also packten
die zigarette ein pakt mit den diamanten
reinpacken das gesicht rhein und die
melone rein natürlich das klappt nicht
packen wir noch den text rein und dann
haben wir glückwunsch student ja sogar
den maulwurf ist das nächste rätsel
ich klicke ihn an da passiert allerdings
nichts von einem mal den hammer
maulwurf
kann
wurf
maulwurf man who was so ach so ich kann
den muss ich so eine rettungsgasse ist
das nächste was hier einfach nur steht
beim dreh zu haben keine richtige
aufgabe allerdings müssen wir
anscheinend die giraffe retten ich weiß
allerdings nicht wie wenn ich das
irgendwie ineinander packten das geht
nicht sie die ganzen sachen mal drauf
das wird allerdings wahrscheinlich auch
nicht klappen genau wie die suche nach
ihrer vierten auch warum klingen ist
denn ja ich wussten paket für die
nachbarn annehmen rädern gerät steht
hier
dein gerät wie sollte ich da denn ohne
tipp drauf kommen kannst du diese frage
lösen einsplus drei plus eins plus ich
kann das nicht mal lesen 12 + 3 + 11 2
+3 +1 1 + 2 plus drei plus eins gleich
also ja das ist ja ganz augenscheinlich
dass es halt 7 ist allerdings ist das
vermutlich falsch eins plus 23 +1 mal
lese ich gebe es auf
ich guck mal so eine werbung ein
unternehmen wir uns den tipp
dieser verdammte fisch alter also wir
haben jetzt eine tipp münze von daher
gibt 93
ich habe bei 35 aufgehört mir meiner
taktik finde das objekt heraus steht nun
hier
hier können wir nicht sagen wir können
allerdings auch nicht so weiblen auch
nichts vergrößern
finde das objekt heraus wollen wir
sachen einfach wir müssen einfach wieder
die sachen hier finden die modells
erwartet dann drücke ich mir hier so ein
bisschen rum hier so ein bisschen ich
finde absolut gar nichts
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der katalog amon ein so so hat
verschlafen vecsey auf als allererstes
würde ich ein wecker nehmen das geht
allerdings nicht mit dem rund geht's
auch nicht mit der fliege auch nie mit
dem hammer natürlich auch nicht kann ich
nicht englisch etwas größer ziehen
es gibt auch nicht die tür
[Applaus]
an welcher besser wird zuerst voll okay
das ist interessant wir haben oben einen
wasserhahn der füllt das darunter dann
geht zuerst geht das wasser auf jeden
fall nach links da geht es runter also
einer von 13 und 4 kann ich einfach
ja der
hö
dieses alles falsch definitiv müsste es
vier sein weil das wasser zuerst hier
untergeht dann gehts hier die einzelnen
geht es in die 4
aber warum ist das falsch
bitte
finde einfach aus meinem leben also wir
haben wieder einen tipp von michael ich
da mal drauf es gibt einen falschen
becher bitte entfernen ihn zuerst also
ich muss anscheinend irgendein
ich mache das leicht aggressiv bewege
ein streichholz um die größte zahl zu
erhalten okay wir müssen ein streichholz
bewegen um die größte zahl zu erhalten
haben gerade 369
von daher muss unsere zahl größer sein
als 369
wenigstens haben wir jetzt schon eine
katzen werbung jetzt bin ich echt mal
gespannt was der tipp zeigt 1965 also
wir sollten anscheinend nach so dass ich
auch selbst drauf kommen können
bitte schreiben die richtige antwort auf
1 221 2 +3 gleich 36 3 + 4 gleich 43
keinen sinn also was man halt direkt
erkennt ist das 1+2 gleich 21 das ist
einfach 21 umgedreht dann auch bei 3+ 4
ist es so 43 umgedreht bei 2 +3 muss ich
allerdings erkennen was da besonders ist
um das dann auf 45 anzuwenden also wir
haben wieder ein tipp bekommen ich bin
echt gespannt was ist die antwort auf 4
+ 5 in klammern 9
das ist jetzt nicht wahr als dennoch
das ist nicht euer ernst
das ist nicht mein gott dieses spiel
macht mich so verdammt aggressiv kommen
das nächste reduziert ohne den noch eine
werbung hier rein zu drücken hier hilft
um ihre aufmerksamkeit zu erregen sie
hatten raus gelten diamanten porsche
[Applaus]
finden wir den außerirdischen aha jetzt
haben wir wieder die richtig dummen
rätsel für mich das ufo kann hin und
herfliegen er ist es falsch die sonne
ist falsch hier ist falsch hier ist
falsch ist falsch vielleicht könnten wir
wieder ich kann mir da irgendwas größer
ziehen wieder näher hier das irgendwie
hier umkreis oder auch den auf die
sonnen edison und darauf auf
nemo
was runter doch weiter geht die wilde
fahrt hier klickt man auf das ding hier
findet die füße des außerirdischen und
ziehe das raumschiff darüber wir müssen
die füße finden müssen
hier das raumschiff darüber das habe ich
doch auch nach jedem rätsel denke ich
mir mensch luca doch auch selbst
aufkommen müssen
von daher jetzt weiter geht s direkt und
ohne rätsel
sonst ist das video vorbei korrigiere
die richtung hoch runter a-jugend
jugendlicher
student wie viele pommes gibt es unten
123456 natürlich denkt man jetzt man
muss allerdings die pommes zählen von 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 906 sind
654 ach so
es sind mal 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
jetzt muss ich nur noch zehn jahre
runterscrollen wieder bei der 10 been a
sehr gut genau da sind die zehn stück
sehr gut habe ich ihn gekriegt gute
arbeit finde erneut den panda wieso
erneut ich muss noch nie ein panda
suchen da da da sehr gut du bist so
schlau dankeschön das hat mir nie jemand
gesagt hätte dreimal auf das
orangefarbene rechteck und dann fünfmal
auf das grüne rechtecke also erst mal
123 12 34 sprachen lernen an der stelle
wo ich das heute wieder zahlen beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch der
mittlerweile schon zweite teil von
brainard gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video daten
schreibt immer und in die kommentare
ob ich eventuell die tage auch einen
dritten teil hochladen soll mich macht
das irgendwie aggressiv aber irgendwie
macht mir auch spaß und jetzt befinden
uns auch schon auto bei einer lieben
freundin oben findet ihr ein smiley
eingewendet wenn ihr der optik könnte
man kanal kostenlos abonnieren wenn ich
schon aber dann würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr auf die glocke klickt denn dann
verpasste keine videos mehr und bekommt
direkt eine benachrichtigung wenn ich
was neues hoch laden und hier ist ein
video verlinkt das ist eben auf meinem
zweit kanal hochgeladen habe
da geht es um youtuber dem tv
bloßgestellt wurden
[Musik]